Andy movius build ships but instead of
sailing them he puts them into bottles
it's a passion that demands dexterity
the mast and sails are only adjusted and
the rigging glued on once the ship is in
the bottle Mobius exhibits his ships and
bottles several times a year and he also
gives courses mine it's been a dream
welcome i'm andy mobius i build ships
and bottles here in baulkham I've been
coming here regularly for over 20 years
and I want to show you the most
beautiful places on this island and
bloom the up ring of course as a trained
shipbuilder his first recommendation
takes us through the town of baulkham to
the coast
welcome has four main beaches
Maya FNP my first recommendation is ball
comes notched on beach it's perfect for
anyone who is looking for peace and
quiet you're under you can breathe
freely here wide open spaces the sea in
summer you can go swimming in winter you
can walk it's a great place to enjoy
nature on Victoria 13 only not were to
be nice just sand and June's as far as
the eye can see almost 500 metres wide
this is Balkans largest and most empty
beach
Andy Mobius comes here whenever he has
time to enjoy the healthy north sea air
and of course the water
therefore very refreshing it's late
autumn but the water still tempting it's
not exactly warm but very healthy nikada
vom about Santa's own
health is also on the agenda and his
second recommendation the other man
here's my second tip for you get site in
Lunt it's a swimming pool and health spa
not just the thing when it's stormy and
rainy outdoors come with me come survive
harm it
the good site and spa is on the islands
southwestern beach Andy Mobius usually
goes to the sauna complex here
the panorama sauna offers a great view
of the North Sea
of course you can enjoy the view from
the terrace as well
from here you can see as far as the seal
colonies not I wasn't promising too much
was I
Andy Mobius is third recommendation is
at the other end of the island the
Borkum riff lightship is one of the
islands landmarks it served as a
floating lighthouse until 1988 it was
moored near an especially dangerous
sandbag to warn other ships it be
finding with it I'm now in the bridge of
the Ibaka Malaysia and that means a lot
to me because I have a very special
relationship with this ship euro civ
then thousands of ships in bottles were
built on board the vessel and that's a
tradition I'm continuing ships were even
built in these light bulbs this is an
original bulb from the lightship from
poorer now I'll take you below deck
maybe cement a dick this is where crew
members used to while away the time by
building ships and bottles now the space
houses an exhibition on the Lower Saxony
wadden sea National Park
these either enter
it's just one of the many reasons why
Andy Mobius enjoys coming to walk around
time and again
you